movie but it's a fact of life at the end
of the day it gets to a point where
everybody's got the internet everybody
can read everybody knows what's going on
bro so many people are woke and know
exactly what's going on but at the same
time it hasn't changed why doesn't it
never change because it's actually still
something quite recent if you think
about it actually when must be in rush
like 70s no when was it the 70s right
well so which means that actually you've
only had about like 50 years in a
country that is absolutely not yours
coming from the absolute bottom to get
somewhere and then not only that then
the Africans came even after which means
you're playing from far far far behind
we've still got a lot of catching up to
do and that is why we cannot actually
really go tooham on black men and two
ham on black women we need to be a bit
more forgiving and understand we are
catching up with centuries of other
people already being ahead in the race
because we're not in our land we're not
in our countries so when we get to these
places we're all the black community in
general is more likely to be living in
the worst places which means that we
will have less likely to have access to
Great education we have less
opportunities we are still probably
dealing with a lot of stuff that we
shouldn't be dealing with at this point
the traumas this is that so it's a cycle
that we're trying to break out of but it
doesn't happen we live in we live in a
time in in we live in a time in history
where that we're living in the age of
the internet and information about you
have no excuse to be ignorant but that's
it I'm saying
that listen listen let me just say this
the time of you're talking about the
wind rush and the Africans came over
after and blah blah blah they didn't
have the internet didn't have access
they didn't know what you did we if
you're always here you didn't know what
was going in going on in Detroit you
didn't know I'll explain something but
now we do know we don't know because you
know what happened with
[Laughter]
is in the less privileged and areas the
b-a-m-e group they were the ones that
were struggling the most because at home
they did not have laptops or access to
the internet one and then two going on
the internet and learning and getting
information
come out bro it does it's not about
winning it is Wednesday
how can you talk about something that
happened for okay we was on lockdown for
what a year bro how long was the
internet out before that and how many
people have access to the internet
that's the whole point the point is not
to act like who everybody has at this
what trust me bro you know I didn't go
to you can go to McDonald's and use free
Wi-Fi bro what are you talking about
okay and you're so so how do you know
have access to the internet they have
access to Internet in libraries
McDonald's the gym there's lots of
outlets you can use free internet can I
comment on this yeah go on so in the
mirror a lot of this stuff came from
America right and so let me let me like
run through it we had the best shows in
the 70s and 80s The Cosby Show when I
was growing up
if you like even even early 2000s if you
weren't going to HBCU you were trash
right like it was it it was you know
they were wearing the shirts it was a
totally different vibe and it started
with Flavor of Love with Flavor Flav and
that show and then all of this stuff
started like 10 years ago and now you
have lizzo and Megan and stallion all
these people and the white people they
celebrate her but they don't you will
never see a white woman in media that
looks like her and so I feel like we we
took this bait as a you know they think
it's empowerment all these different
things but literally coming up the only
thing we saw on TV were educated black
people on on those sitcoms like Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air and like a strong
Father Strong family talking about real
issues and now look at what's on when
you see black people on TV so and like
it was a totally different vibe so it's
not about sevid or like all these other
things yes they're there but the sitcom
I mean you would cry because of what
they were talking about racism right
like Carlton and you know and uh will
they like were arrested I remember that
episode I remember that episode yeah you
don't see that anymore all you see is
Liz oh and and all these guys who you
see now is rappers what rappers are
doing bruh you go on Instagram go on any
of these um these very popular Pages all
you see is what rapper what jewelry
rappers are buying from ice box but dude
that's all you see bro and listen I
don't I'm not saying it like I think I'm
better than anyone I wear chain yeah
boom I never said I'm betting at anyone
but once your eyes are open it's open I
know that this is crap and this is what
I was saying now I'm I'm at the stage
where I can make friends with anyone
anyone bro you could see me walking down
the street with him even though we look
completely different but back in the day
my mindset was just like the typical
black guy you walking oh I can't be
around no one that ain't like me and I
don't rate them and the problem is a lot
of us still have that mindset now and
even if into their old age they still
have that mindset bro but do you think
that
the black community is at fault for that
or do you think because you know we're
speaking about all these things but
let's not forget who owns the media yeah
he's social engineering so no it's
indoctrination people are trying to push
a certain narrative down minorities
fruit so that we start believing certain
things about each other and we reinforce
it even ourselves yeah so I think I I
get that I get that you know we should
stop reinforcing these things within our
community but let's not carry all the
blame like we
as minorities didn't even weren't even
able to make up to these certain places
at certain points in time because there
were so many barriers there that didn't
even allow us like how many black-owned
newspapers that are mainstream out there
like do we know about no yeah but
nobody's thinking about that nobody's
feelings but no one in school is
thinking about it they're thinking I
want to play football I want to do music
everybody wants to do music everybody
everybody that's because what they see
that's what they see okay yeah but this
is because yeah because because they
don't we don't see the depiction just
like The Cosby Show and the French Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air we don't see that
anymore yeah all we see is rappers with
all these girls twerking everywhere and
you see get now now it has evolved into
women actually object to find themselves
yeah
so
um
like isn't that across to all cultures
because I think like we are now living
in the Western World so it's not just
amongst black people he's amongst white
people too yeah it is it it does cross
boundaries but it has destroyed the
black communities especially black
communities in the west the worst like
there's no comparison do you get what
I'm saying every every negative thing
out there is associated to black people
every negative thing yeah and that's why
and that's the truth I think it's it
would be very responsible instead of
saying oh black girls have attitude no
explain black girls you're likely to
have more attitude because of X Y and Z
black men you're more likely to do be
doing these things that are negative
because of X Y and Z instead of blaming
because you cannot get people to have
accountability for things that they
don't even know about teach people more
about themselves teach them more about
what they come from and they will know
do you know what I mean and I think that
the problem with the black community and
why there's so much confusion is because
we are still trying to find ourselves in
a place that is nothing to do with us we
need to go back to our roots and
understand where do we come from what
actually drives us what sets ourselves
on fire because the black community no
matter where you are in the world we all
share a similar experience which is
similar which is a feeling of almost
rejection even in your own continent
there's a feeling of rejection came in
Portugal right
um would you say that
um
it is a is a commonplace thing where
black guys who kind of have that
stereotype of like a criminal or Fargo
or Street guy do they do well with women
in Portugal
do you see them like with the best
looking with like a lot of times you see
them from very good looking women in in
Portugal no no not really in it yeah
it's actually the successful black man
that can get so they're right so it's
the the educated Guy the one that's a
doctor lawyer they usually do the best
they with the bad bees yeah the the
proper the gentleman black man is the
one that can have access to like the
finer babe especially in terms of white
women as well okay so like like okay you
got amongst your friends YouTube use
back home in Portugal yeah lesser
exclude like the older generation or
your family or whatever people that will
judge you and tell you off yeah if you
was to say oh
let's even say you used to bring me
there yeah and I was fully Disturbed
listen and I was fully The Stereotype I
look like yeah yeah teeth chain tats
everything yeah what how would your
friends
respond
but honestly but in my area there's a
lot of guys like you so it doesn't you
guys like me do well with the ladies
yeah so they do like guys that look like
liquor stores he's got some
self-interest dude he's trying to go to
Portugal no no no I'm trying to make a
plan I'm trying to make a point kind of
but it depends because I think that
Portugal it's not very much like the UK
where everything is so integrated so you
may do well with a certain kind of type
but you will definitely not do that with
another type it's almost like a 50 50.
you know there's still a lot of like
separation in that sense in Portugal I
think because of like colonization and
the relationship that Portuguese have
with Africa there's higher expectations
for a black man to be kind of accepted
into a certain part of the so so you're
saying a black man would have to be very
successful to be accepted in those
certain Corners in certain in in a lot
of Corners festivals in most Corners in
a lot of Corners unless it's like a
community of uh in Portugal that is used
to having yeah what do you think about
it you look like you want to object no I
just wanted to go back a little bit
because I think like in Portugal there's
not this culture of like bad bees and
stuff it's not the same as here he's
different I think like it's big cities
like I don't know London like Miami
whatever I think that's like that that
culture is there like the bad big
culture you ain't got the Instagram
models in Portugal yeah you do but it's
not the same as here like I think here
there's a lot of like focus on social
media and like how you look and oh let
me go to the club and be in the VIP like
stuff like that so you look don't do
that there no not as much like it's
completely different in it yeah it's
completely different like you don't go
to the club and you know what just to
show that like I'm a bad boy whatever as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible